I grew up primarily in suburban New
Jersey not far from New York City where
my parents worked and I think I'm very
much a product of the you know middle
class upper middle-class suburban
environment that I grew up in an
environment in which achievement in
school and achievement in the
professional world beyond school were
you know very very high values and I
think that you know shaped me
tremendously well I usually say that I
got into journalism because the family
business my parents met when they were
the successive editors of the
undergraduate newspaper at NYU where
they were both commuter students my
father went on to spend his entire
career in journalism primarily the late
great New York Herald Tribune and then
for 35 years of Time magazine so I grew
up carrying a little reporters pad and
pencil in my pocket just imitating my
father and as a child for me a big
adventure was to come into the city from
New Jersey to visit him at the time and
life building and send messages through
the old pneumatic tubes and play ping
pong in the hallway with the other
journalists people who I thought were
these exotic kooky off-the-wall people
and I thought it was just the coolest
thing in the world and my father worked
with these people I so as a kid I just
assumed I was going to become a
journalist because that's what people
did when they got older